coming up you know red it's one of my
it's just
such a powerful color e.t has got you
covered on all things fashion from the
93rd annual oscars
from the stunning skin bearing moments
one more wave
to the men charming their way across the
carpet
plus the ladies who brought big drama on
hollywood's biggest night
with their gorgeous red carpet looks
right down the middle right here
perfect hello everyone and welcome to
et lives the download i'm denny directo
with sunday's oscars
red carpet fashion was back and bolder
than ever
to help me break down the biggest trends
that we saw at the academy awards i'm
lucky enough to be joined by
bevy smith media personality and author
of bevellations lessons from a mother
auntie bessie she's got right there in
her hands and et's senior style editor
marisa
runyon hello ladies
let's get right into it the first trend
of the night skin
for the win we saw so many women just
daring in these gowns with some sexy
cutouts
and they weren't share afraid to bear a
little skin let's start with
zendaya she was a presenter last night a
lot of people were talking about this
valentino look
that we got to see yesterday uh it's
this yellow silk chiffon gown but also
apparently
it glows in the dark as well y'all i
mean la roche
always turns it out with z uh bevy let's
start with you what made this look so
darien and so bold what did you think of
it
well i mean it really wasn't it was
paying homage it was a complete
throwback to share
i mean you know we have a complete look
that is exactly as a doppelganger
so i just love that you know again
zendaya is showing why she is
a red carpet staple and of course to be
reckoned with
when it comes to style and i'm always so
proud of her because she's so
young and normally it takes people at
least a decade to be able to slay the
red carpet but she's been doing this for
so long now she's an og at this
even though she's still a baby oh she's
a definitely a style queen for sure i
mean we've seen her all season long
really turn it out
marissa what about this look surprised
you
well i i mean it's hard not to be
surprised by zendaya because
her partnership with laroche stylist is
is so
symbiotic like they really work together
on a creative level that i think is
transcends the red carpet i mean every
look that she comes out with
is is a really big moment so this i mean
he actually joked on his instagram this
morning that uh he brought the wind too
for this red carpet moment because it
was such a vision she was such a vision
it was such a moment
but she also has a really effortless way
of wearing clothes
and and existing on the red carpet even
while wearing six million dollars worth
of bulgarian jewels which she was last
night
so i mean i'm always surprised by her
but in the best way
i got to tell you what surprised me most
about her and why i'm consistently
impressed is like
obviously she is um she's so fashion
forward but obviously with this nod to
share
she respects like all those looks that
came before her in a lot of ways and i
feel like
collaborating with la roche they always
want to make it a moment
and even the wind knew it they're like
you're wearing chiffon you're wearing
soap
let me let me blow it effortlessly for
you
on this red carpet it really was
something else uh but let's just
oh i'm sorry i'll go ahead and just say
really quick you know the 70s style is
really her thing
she loves that kind of stuff that was
something that she paid homage to when
she did her tommy hill figure
collaboration with laura roach um and so
this is really her like wheelhouse
she loves chic 70s style she knows what
she's doing you know
but another style stand out on the red
carpet at the oscars yesterday was
carrie mulligan it was a dress you could
see a mile away
but also within the audience there at
the oscars she was wearing valentino
hot uh carrie was fully on trend from
last night i mean between the gold
the cutouts even the drama of the train
uh bevy what was your reaction when you
first saw this on the red carpet
i didn't like it at all i thought it was
really fitting i thought it looked like
um something that you're going to see
a lot of for prom which is a great thing
for prom
um i thought that it was ill-fitting for
her
um when you see the look on the runway i
thought it looked much better i don't
know i thought the proportions were
weird on her um and i didn't i
absolutely didn't love it i think it's a
beautiful
but i i think she could have done
something different
marissa your thoughts did you feel like
carrie wore the dress or did the dress
wear her
you know the dress was wearing her a
little bit i have to agree with bevy but
i did appreciate that she came to us
with a really big moment
because in a year of being so subdued
this was the moment that i was really
hoping for
a big gown and a really big presence
especially on such a big night for her
being nominated for best actress so
on that level i really appreciated her
coming out with a big look
but i do think it was it was a lot of
volume for her
i think with the the that reflection
like the iridescence
of that gown maybe it should have been a
different shade like maybe like pearl
like actual white i don't know if that
would look too bridal but
you know i was also reminded of like the
the you know the tube top kind of moment
with the cutouts
the bando thank you the bando remind me
of taylor swift when she wore that bando
with the two like really
hot colors at the grammys and i feel
like if you're comparing those two
taylor won it yeah yeah
uh but you know what someone else who
wore cut out and gold was
andra day i'm so excited to hear what
you guys thought about this because
she really i mean this is her first time
being nominated as an actress for an
academy award and
she looked like a winner in this very
vera wang and it was accustomed to
also low-key inspired by cher marissa
let's start with you this gown
actually involved an unexpected
technique to create it what can you tell
us about how it was made
yes so this is custom vera wang and vera
wang actually just rebranded her entire
brand
so this is vera wang oate which is kind
of short for okator so it's
couture light but basically this whole
dress the fabric was actually a chain
metal
like a chainmail metal so she used
welders to help put this dress together
and actually weld it together so that's
why it has that liquid gold
uh feel across her body because it
really is it's liquid metal on her
yeah bevy you know if people uh know
andrew day as the singer they'll know
that this is a total transformation from
when we first met her you know she
always had that retro vibe and now look
at her
on the oscars red carpet how excited are
you to see andra's
style evolution well you know what
here's the thing about andrew you can
never really predict what she's going to
do
but she actually said that this gown was
really paying homage to billy holliday
billy holiday loved lingerie so she
wanted to make sure she showed skin she
wanted to be sexy
also her stylist rory vice who also did
her the musician her
um rory told me that andrew actually had
a
dress very similar to this in her car in
her closet
but it was a mini skirt and she said i
want to wear this and he said well
darling we have to wear a gown
so that's how the collaboration between
river wang
and um rory and andrew came about so
this is also it was something that was
inspired from her closet and you know
andrew's the girl that wants to be
comfortable she's also the girl
who's always going to buck the system
and go her own way so i'm not surprised
by this at all also i love love love her
tiffany's jewelry
i love a classic moment with such a racy
kind of 1970s
disco moment it was so good and you know
her the inspiration behind this oscars
glam is something she opened up to et's
michelle turner about just last month
let's take a look
one of my goals with the dress i was
talking to this incredible designer
and i told her i want to wear something
that andra day right quote unquote would
not have typically worn before billie
holiday
she helped me to own my own vocal and
artistic identity when i was like 11 12.
and so i want an homage to how she sort
of helped me own my own womanhood now
playing her in this season of my life we
love to see it and we also love to see
a costume change she actually switched
into a metallic ensemble
for her after party look just as daring
just as
sexy just as perfect i mean she's
dripping
in that silver metallic what did you
guys think of it oh this
uh do you know it was actually a dance
party and it was filled with her family
and friends
most of the cast from the united states
versus lily holiday was there including
my daughter's son
miss lawrence so he said it was a
full-on dance party and i think that's
the reason why
she wanted to wear something that like
that but also paired with those chunky
shoes
so she could really party hard
throughout the night and not to worry
about
painful feet so she could celebrate and
so she can move
i love it i love it but you know you
guys it wasn't just the ladies who
really turned it out at the oscars let's
talk about the men who really stepped
outside beyond
the tuxedo starting with leslie odom jr
he was a pre-show performer and of
course a nominee
and for the night he rocked that gold
brianni brione excuse me sue
uh it was so good dripping in gold i'm
not sure we've ever seen a tux like this
at the oscars ever
marissa what do we know about the style
details on this one
so this is a custom-made briony suit for
him
uh and briony actually uses gold
24 karat gold and silk threads so this
suit was actually made with
real gold he's a real walking statue
here and the only
the only people who can use this gold
thread really are briony and
the vatican breoni also supplies this
gold threat to the vatican so
he's really truly royalty last night and
i
honestly i i would give him my best
dress of the night i thought this look
was so unexpected he wore it so well
and really when you add up all the looks
he gave us through the whole night
best dressed i mean i love a daring
moment he gave us three
bevy do you agree how do you think
leslie pulled this off
i mean i didn't absolutely love this
rioni suit but i do give him an
a for effort because i love the fact
that he was trying to channel
the oscar a chocolatey oscar
um so you know it's like manifesting
what he really wanted unfortunately he
did not go home with the gold but he was
fortunate enough to be able to go home
with this suit
which is it's quite beautiful i don't
know how many times you can wear it
again but you know it's it was
definitely chic
but i'm far more a bigger fan of his um
white
giron chi suit that he wore when he
performed that was beautiful and chic
and stunning
and looked far more modern to me i mean
look at that fabulous lock detail there
and look at the chunky um chain jewelry
it just was
so incredible and i wish he had worn
this on the red carpet i think
it would have been a lot more of a
moment
it's so sleek and you know he phil he
finished off the
night with an after-party look that we
have to talk about as well it's
valentino then this turquoise he's going
for this like monochromatic look
and i'm not mad at this baby i'm gonna
kick it back right to you this
matching turtleneck oversized
button-down shirt moment by valentino
what did you think
i thought it was beautiful he he's
full-on dripping them pastels this is a
really
big trend for all of us this um spring
we should all be wearing pastels
and leslie olim jr has definitely led
the way for the men
so they should all take note every guy
that we're with and hanging out with
should be in pastel this summer
amen and you know another gent that
really took a risk last night
lakeith stanfield in st i mean
yeah looking at this i'm like i have
never seen anything like this at the
oscars
marissa i feel like i mean you tell me
do you think we'll see more men take
risks like this
at the oscars post pandemic because this
year felt a little different right
um i feel like i don't know there's a
style rule here that's meant to be
broken
because he really pulled it off i hope
that this was the year that changes it
for the oscars because you know we i was
so bored of the plain black tux i think
we need to stop that
and so many men to have these bold
fashion moments
i mean this suit was so unexpected so
cool i
i want to rip this off his body and wear
it myself like anthony vacarello please
send it to my house
i i'm obsessed with it and i love that
we saw so many minutes so
in jewelry last night as well so he
paired this with a gold chain
and the glasses i thought he looked very
cool and very comfortable in his own
skin
and very powerful absolutely did you
think you look fly bevy
oh yeah definitely but i think we can't
underestimate the fact that inclusivity
and diversity
this is what happens when you do this
this means that we have
great different types of style on the
red carpet
because it was the men of color um last
night that really did stand out now this
i love because it's saint laurent
and it's actually um inspired by
a real woman's jumpsuit from the saint
laurent spring
2021 collection so he took this
they modified it for him and he put the
big white uh you know shirt with the
huge lapels on there
and and voila but i love that he's
always
fearless as far as um androgyny he's so
secure in his masculinity
that he'll wear wigs any time the day or
night you know he'll wear this
jumpsuit that was inspired by a woman's
jumpsuit
so he's just bold and courageous and i
love it
all courageous and fashion forward uh
switching gears then cause someone who
really stuck to script
was brad pitt he did wear more typical
black tuxedo
but marissa maybe you could talk a
little bit about how brat or why brad
maybe took this classic look beyond the
tux
well brad pitt is an ambassador for
briony which is who he was wearing last
night so
briony is a italian men's suiting and
tuxedo
you know designer so he's going to wear
a classic tux at the oscars i think
that's kind of a given but
i think what we really loved about him
is how easy
and effortless it is for him to be in
the tux and now he just took his hair
swept it back into his little man bun
and you know
strolled out on the oscar stage that's
exactly what we all wanted
especially last night with the awards
show kind of dragging on and not feeling
you know like the oscars we once knew
we all needed that uplifting brad moment
so i think that's why we had to include
him here
you're right i just people were
definitely excited yeah they were were
you excited about me
i when i saw him come out no i was not i
mean i just didn't want to see another
black tuxedo and there he was in a black
tuxedo
and the man bum for me was not thrilling
because we've seen jared leto
honestly do it for our better so i'm
just like oh there's brad pitt good on
him
you go boy there was something nostalgic
about that little hair bun that did it
for me though
because i just feel like i i haven't
seen it in a really long time brad
really put his hair back like
legends of the fall a little you know
interview with a vampire moment
and maybe because as uh marissa pointed
out this was a moment in the show where
i needed something like this like to get
excited about because i was kind of you
know falling asleep
so when i maybe were getting more credit
than he deserved but man he looks good i
gotta just say that
no he definitely looks good yeah he
looks good
right exactly the man is literally
benjamin button and speaking of young
people
let's talk about alan kim he of course
was not nominated but part of the cast
of minari
uh wearing this custom tom brown moment
with the little
tuxedo shorts in the school uniform i
mean i loved it so much
marissa were you surprised to see shorts
on the red carpet
no not not on someone like him i mean
this is a classic like
twist on a school uniform type moment
this is kind of what we see
you know um prince george prince louis
and when they were young
we see them in shorts so i thought this
was very appropriate and
absolutely adorable he just looks so
precious this was like
a huge fashion moment for a little kid i
loved it
you even had a blowout i mean i was here
forever what did you think
oh i thought he was adorable but i don't
think he's the first man um
a young man or man at all um to wear
um shorts on the oscar red carpet i want
to say pharrell did it
that's right shorts on the oscars red
carpet
yeah we have it right here this is
pharrell in 2014.
and that i was surprised when i saw
these shorts on the red carpet
uh maybe less surprised when i saw alan
kim in it but uh
again men taking chances though we're
here for it
the drama of it all shall we get right
into it amanda
seyfried in this giorgio armani prive
hibiscus red ball gown i mean this is
the kind of drama
and glamour i come to expect at the
academy awards but marissa what did it
for you
i love seeing red on the red carpet and
this was a very big moment for her being
nominated for an oscar
so i love that she matched the look with
the moment
so you know usually a red gown with a
red lip on the red carpet
it can kind of it's could be seen as
expected but there's something really
modern about this dress
that made it a little unexpected i think
it was the illusion neckline
the way that the draping uh flowed
across her
it was it was really beautiful just a
plus beautiful
bevy what was your reaction to amanda's
dress i absolutely loved it you know we
were talking before we went on air and i
was saying that traditionally
i hate old hollywood glamour but because
we didn't see a lot of that on the red
carpet this year
this was actually bold and unexpected
and i thought that you know anytime you
can wear armani pre-bay
and this please say tool i mean just
look at that look at the construction on
that gown
that gown stands up just like that even
when her body is not in it it's just
perfectly constructed and of course
giorgio armani
is the father of the red carpet fashions
and so it shows why people go to him
time and again
but i thought she was beautiful and i
thought it was so appropriate
because she stars in mank which is all
about orson welles
and takes place around the 1930s 1940s
and so the glamour look
really fit perfectly for her role in the
film she was absolutely paying homage to
it too and i got to tell you
seeing it during the telecast and the
audience too it really stood out to me
it was the red but also because of the
tool and the train i thought she looked
stunning
and earlier this month amanda told et's
michelle turner about why she chose
the bold look i think honestly i had a
really good red moment at the last
oscars i went to which was about 10
years ago
and i think i uh i think i've been
missing that it's the author we're back
every we're we are commencing the
backness
of this of society
someone else who had a very good red
moment at the oscars last night
angela bassett she wore this custom
alberta ferretti
number with that bow detailing in the
back and before we get into it all in an
exclusive one-on-one with et's kevin
frazier last night angela explained how
this dramatic look
kind of came together at the last minute
and we started working on it maybe about
a week and a couple of days ago
my stylist jennifer uh she just had this
vision in her head
and and they they went at it i mean and
i just wait until today to put it on
now bevy do we believe that angela just
trusted her stylist walked into the room
put on the dress and said okay i'm ready
let's go to the red carpet
yes because if you know anything about
angela bassett you know that she is a
very decisive woman
you also know that if um she lives by
the ruler
if you stay ready you ain't got to get
ready so she keeps that body tight and
right
all year round so of course she can like
simply go to the album
already and say yes gown and then put it
on and it's going to be
perfect i just love love love this and i
again want to applaud her for being a 62
year old woman
who shows that it gets greater later she
is a world-class
timeless beauty and also a world-class
red carpet slayer
and tonight i mean last night was no
different
i mean come on i agree with you right
there marissa what do you think is it
just me or does angela
just get better with age she's flawless
she really is i
appreciated the drama of this look and i
really loved her hair and makeup last
night i
i just love the simplicity of her hair i
love that she did this dramatic eye
in the in a navy shade so it's something
a little bit different a little
unexpected it really complemented the
red in a way i would never have
anticipated so i mean
there's nothing nothing bad to say about
this i loved it
and marissa can we also just talk about
the fact that most women of any age are
very afraid to do something so heavy
underneath the eye because we all know
that that's a problem for
many of us women especially as you get
older that skin gets really thin
but not angela bassett darling she's
like black don't crack
she needs to drop that skincare routine
she used to drop that skincare
you know someone else who really brought
out a more dramatic look on the red
carpet at the oscars is her
she wore this hand beaded custom
jumpsuit and cape from dundas
uh but what's so cool about it if you
guys look closely it's embellished with
lyrics from her nominated song
fight for you of course she wore her
signature glasses as well but i thought
this was
a real wow moment marissa i know that
her paid tribute to another
fellow musician turned oscar winner what
can you tell us
that's right so she was sponsored by
prince
sponsored she was inspired by prince
can you imagine being sponsored by
prince would be the best thing ever so
she was inspired by a look that he wore
in 1985
when uh he went to the oscars and was uh
when he won actually best original song
just like she did so
i guess it really worked it was quite a
good luck charm so
you know you can really see the
similarities between the shade
the cape the drama and she still managed
to look just like her and i think that
sounds just like her i think that's so
important on the red carpet too
is that you never want to feel like a
star doesn't look like themselves you
never want to feel like the look is
wearing them and she
never ever looks like that she always
looks very comfortable
uh in no matter how dramatic the look is
which is what i love did you feel did
you agree bevy that this was totally a
look that she would
wear anywhere else like it was very very
her
worried vice is rory vices andrade
stylist
and also her stylist and he told me that
um you know her
to be so young she has a very definitive
idea about the way she likes to look
so it's always a collaborative effort
with her and so that's
that's truly the case with this and i'm
so happy that she won
and just like marissa said paying homage
to prince
on the same you know in the same regard
that he won as well many years
we can't absolutely well we can't talk
bold and daring without talking about
regina king's outfit last night she's
wearing custom louis vuitton
and this dress took over 140 hours to
make not to mention it contains 62 000
sequins y'all
uh bevy i feel like regina can never do
any wrong especially this past awards
season she has slayed slate slate
um how do you think her oscars dress
compared to what we've seen here in this
past year
well you know what um virginia king is
getting bolder and bolder with her red
carpet style you have to remember
she's been in the business for about 40
years at this point which is insane
but for many years she didn't have
access to these amazing gowns like
you know this louis vuitton moment and
so now that she
is the star that she is and everyone
wants to dress her she's taking full
advantage of it
and she's also very much collaborating
with her stylist raymond and micah who
do
an incredible job on her i thought this
was so great
it's architecturally important with the
sleeves um and also of course it pays a
little bit of hummus to an art deco
moment
so she was just perfect and divine in
every way marissa did you feel like she
saved the best for last year at the
oscars
oh i absolutely did and especially
having that moment at the beginning of
the show
when the camera just follows her all the
way into the venue
i mean that was the platform that this
gown and that she needed
i loved seeing it from every angle she
looked flawless
all right you guys we're winding down
here but before we go i
have to get your guys's thoughts on one
other fashion standout
halle berry's new haircut she chopped it
off right before the show
a bevy a hairdo or a hair don't
what we have to say is that here don't
edit the mode from the incredibles
no one wants a piece of that um people
were saying okay she must have lost
isaiah again she looked really stressed
out
the hair looked like it was a tantrum
oh that's so good marissa what did you
make of the haircut
i am not a fan of this look i i think
it's very severe and she's so beautiful
that you know anyone as beautiful as
halle berry should be able to pull it
off but it's just too severe for me
i'm kind of hoping that this was just
for the oscars
and maybe this is on the way back to a
pixie cut or something that i really
love on her
uh dear abergel another hair stylist
does this with his client uh
charlize theron for the oscars well
he'll do something really dramatic and
then they'll move on and change it so
i'm hoping that was it
you would think we'd be talking about
howling our new boyfriend making the red
carpet debut but because of that haircut
we can't stop talking about that but
maybe we'll get him on another one in
the meantime
bevi smith marissa ryan thank you guys
so much for talking all things oscar's
fashion
and thank you guys for tuning in make
sure you download that et live app so
you don't miss another episode of the
download and of course we have all
your oscars coverage on our website et
online.com
we'll see you guys tomorrow take care
[Music]
you